[Music]
woman returns from vacation to find
family home mistakenly
demolished an employee admitted he had
the wrong address after he checked the
permit but the company has taken no
other
action dude they demolished the
lady's
house in Atlanta dude this would only
happen in Atlanta Atlanta's
crazy you
know I
mean imagine coming
home after a
vacation dude like you spend your hard
earned cash that you [__] you
know you're like oh man finally get to
go on vacation going to relax just going
to all my stress going to be gone by the
time I come home ready to ready to get
back to life and just rock it and you
show up
dude and it's a pile of rubble okay that
happens to me hey dude check this out
that happens to
me everybody I've ever met in my life is
getting
murdered okay I don't I don't give a
[__] who has whose fault it is everybody
I've ever met in the world is getting
murdered okay people I met when I was
seven I got to go back and find John
Middleton or whatever the hell his name
was when I was used to be friends with
him my mom was like that was your first
best friend I don't even remember his
[__] full name I think it was John
Middleton or something but he was blonde
whoever that guy if he's alive he's
getting [__] knifed up
dude sorry dude I I came home for
vacation lost my home I the [__]
there was the wrong address dude and the
guy's going to get stabbed and as he's
getting stabbed he's going to be going
like this I get it it's extreme but I
the [__] the [__] blood coming out
of his mouth I I would do it too you
must be murdering everyone you ever
met
dude could
you IM I can't wait to just walk through
the door of my house and just plop down
on my couch and just start rocking life
again what a great great reset and then
you don't even have a door to walk
through or a couch to plop
down dude imagine Ro driving
up imagine first seeing it a little bit
far away you're
like you're like oh no that's not right
right that's not our it looks like it's
our house like but you're convincing
yourself no no no it's not I can't no no
no no get closer that'd be
me oh my god dude I can't that is the it
doesn't work the oops
button look at her look at the quote I'm
furious hodin said I keep waking up
thinking first of all where are you
waking up is this all a joke or
something just a choke because here's
here's the thing too that happens I go
to oh I'm I'm rich as [__] I'm getting
rich off this somebody's getting sued to
high heaven you know what I'm saying I'm
going to be yo it's going to be Chris is
going to be like you're be like were you
seen you seen Chris lately nope why ah
he's just like [__] he's doing the
ducktail [__] where he dives into the
[__] the the cash from the diving
board he's got that now oh really yeah
oh he's somewhere I haven't talked but I
was his best friend oh but he doesn't
talk to anybody anymore only his family
and he he spends [__] 8 hours a day
off a diving board inside diving into
some coins like [__] DuckTales who is
DuckTales was that Scrooge McDuck that's
Scrooge McDuck that's me I'm changing my
name to Scrooge McDuck that's how
[__] much I'm suing and getting money
for
it oh my God she asked a n she said a
neighbor called her while she was away
and asked if someone had been hired to
DARE tear down the vacant house I said
no and she said well someone well
there's someone over here who just
demolished the whole house and tore it
all
down hey
neighbor stop it before that
happen worst neighbor hey hey guys what
you
doing when The Neighbor confronted them
hod hodon said the workers got nasty he
he told her to shut up and mind her own
business oh dude that's not even their
business mind your own business I'm
[__] destroying the wrong
house oh my
God I would I would get so many millions
of dollars all your pictures for
everyone they're all gone
you know your all your [__] is in there
like computers and
clothes oh man